we touched on this earlier in the
program the idea that the cardinals
either are or aren't currently shopping
josh rose and charlie castle said
earlier this week that last week at the
scouting combine the cardinals were
shopping rosen adam schafter of espn
says they're not he cites sources who
say that teams tried to approach the
cardinals about what it would take to
get rosen last week and the cardinals at
this point gave no indication they're
ready to move on from rose and so i
don't know how we thread this needle i
think the reality is a lot of
conversations happen many of which are
fewed by fueled by alcohol at the
scouting combine so memories may be a
little hazy about what was and wasn't
discussed but but i think that if you're
the cardinals you have to at least begin
to develop an idea chris of what you
could get for rosen because that's a
factor in whether or not you are going
to do this kyle murray for josh rosen
swap yeah no doubt i mean it's a factor
in a lot of ways it can affect your free
agency right i mean if you think okay
we're gonna trade down uh or keep josh
rosen and trade down now you go okay
well we don't need to get these players
and free agency it's a whole balancing
act i guess the biggest thing though is
it's extremely early still in the
process i think this will happen at some
point but yes right now i don't think
the cardinals know exactly what they
want to do they're weighing all options
we know that they you know are fancied
by kyler murray but are they serious we
don't really know that uh so i think
they're not shopping them there's a
difference there when you're shopping
you're calling teams and trying to work
out a trade you've decided you're
getting rid of him right yeah you're
you're we're getting rid of this guy
what are we going to get from you you
stumbled into a very good point there
though if they're going to move josh
rosen maybe they want to sign one of
these veteran quarterbacks that's going
to be available next week right so maybe
they need to move more quickly than we
thought
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports